hey guys Pete here everyone's had a
chance to see all four parts of the new
twin peaks' the return season 3 and this
will be my recap and review for part 4
it will contain spoilers for everything
that has occurred in Twin Peaks season 3
up to this point I'm going to do it in
the way that I did the first one for
part 1 and part 2 so there will be a
recap that goes through all the scenes
and then at the end we'll talk about
what stands out as the most important
pieces what's going on and all that so
there will be a timestamp link in the
description so that if you don't want to
go through the recap you can just skip
ahead to where we talk about what's
kicking around in our heads
after watching part forward hello-oh we
pick back up with agent Cooper and the
silver Mustang Ranch mr. Jack Potts is
still on a roll and even helps out the
old woman by pointing her to the right
machine we see that the casino manager
is worried that coop will ruin him and
then he has hit 30 mega jackpots
course in real life this would never
happen because the casino would stop
things and investigate what was wrong
with the machines not sure if that's
important since we already have the
floating symbol there above the machines
that we know he's getting help from
somewhere but it's so much fun to hear
him going hello that it doesn't really
matter much to me at this part that you
know it's not really that believable
that they would just let him win and pay
him off a new character named bill
shaker approaches coop and fills him in
on some details about hooli nihilism
where he lives he's now officially
dougie Jones from Lancelot court near
Merlin's market so there's some King
Arthur references all around him my
favorite part of this exchange as we
coop notices the hotdogs and sort of
smells at it it shows just how strange
all of this is to him right now and that
he only has a vague idea about letting
what eating is dougie cube tries to
leave after bill mentions there being
cabs right outside but the casino
management stops him and takes him
upstairs to receive his money the scene
is fantastically acted and the gist is
that the casino would be glad to help
him with any
NEADS they don't seem to know who does
you Jones is and if you're unfamiliar
with how casinos work it might be
confusing as to why they do that
basically the house has such an
advantage in odds that Kentucky has
taken so much of their money they want
to treat him well in hopes that he'll
come back to lose that and more they put
him in a limbo home and the driver gets
him there of course he has no idea what
he's supposed to do so they stand
outside for a while we see dougie coupe
looked up and noticed that an owl flies
by eventually Dougie's wife Jamie E
Jones comes out slaps him and explains
not only has he been gone for three days
and missed work but that he also missed
their son Sonny Jim's
birthday she dragged him into the house
and starts to interrogate him she
realizes he has a large bag filled with
cash and he tells her he's mr. jackpots
which was hilarious by the way once she
realizes that he won the money he she
says this is enough to pay them back and
her tone completely changes she doesn't
go as far as to tell us who they are who
needs paid back but she starts being
nice to him and says she's gonna fix him
a sandwich and a piece of Sonny jims
cake and that she's so glad that he's
made it home we catch up with golden
cole who is meeting with denise Bryson
Denise is now the chief of staff of the
entire FBI and seems to have a
connection or an interest of Tammy
Preston who she grills Cola Bell if it's
not a connection it is at least that
she's a little bit jealous of Tammy
beauty is this exchanged between the two
is short and sweet and basically amounts
to coal keeping Denise in the loop there
is a point when Gordon is waiting where
he notices a bouquet of flowers in the
seat next to him and I'm not sure what
the significance of that was we go back
to Twin Peaks and we catch up with Lucy
on the phone about the thermostat and
notice a really odd family portrait on
her desk that looks like a photo of
someone else with photos of the heads of
her Andy and their son Wally sort of
taped over top of them we find out she
was talking on the phone to the current
sheriff Truman when he walks in the
front door this surprises Lucy to the
point of her passing out now Lucy's
always been quirky
when we see here now something seems off
it could be that her behavior has gotten
more erratic but it could also be
hinting at something else either way I'm
going to be paying attention each time I
see her because it seems like you might
be missing something something inside
her story that we haven't seen yet
after Sheriff Frank Truman leads Lucy
with Amy we find out that there's a
whole other modern control center in the
Twin Peaks Sheriff's Department these
days it's down the hall from where Lucy
sits and we found that find out a couple
things in this scene one a boy od'd at
the local school and two the number of
deputies and people working at the
department has grown quite a bit outside
in the hall we find out that Bobby
Briggs is now on the force sheriff
Truman asked him if he knows the boy
Danny Craig who was deep and says he
thinks Chinese designer drugs might be
involved again we find out that Bobby
has you know been working he does
surveillance on the drug trafficking
routes from Canada and II lovingly tries
to explain telephones to Lucy and we
catch a glimpse of just how awesome
guitar is now this is one of their best
teams together and we see that Andi has
real concern about why the cellphone
thing keeps happening
the sheriff is talking to hawk in the
conference room who is telling him what
the log lady had told him and throwing
him in on what's going on we get
introduced to another new deputy here
named Chet who seems like a piece of
work he seems skeptical about what's
going you know what they're talking
about and he drops some funny lines in
relation to Margaret Lander Minh as he's
walking out he's gonna go have a
conversation with his pinecone and
Andy's reaction throughout this to look
at like he looked straight at sheriff
Truman right after everything Chet says
it's pretty hilarious
- Bobby walks into the conference room
and breaks into an awkward bit of crying
when he sees Laura's picture sitting on
the table when he finds out that
everyone's gathered over something
related to agent Cooper he mentions that
coop was the last person to see his
father alive Bobby's mom told him a
couple days after you know major break
died that Cooper had come by to see him
that Cooper had left town shortly after
that Bobby adds a major Briggs died in a
fire at his station the next day this
would be listening post alpha from the
secret history that he's talking about
here so from this weird to presume that
after his Lodge experience and return
back to the Great Northern you know as
what we now see as evil coupe
he went to see major Briggs as a top
priority also that Briggs supposedly
died 25 years ago in a fire before we
get into anything else though another
new guy comes to the door and mentions
that there is a Wally brando outside
Andy and Lucy get excited and go out and
the deputy tells sheriff Truman that
Wally came to pay his respects so he
takes off the scene as well
Bobby starts to cry again as the
sheriff's on his way out and Hawk just
come sort of looks stands there and
looks at him the wall he's seen a
strange look fantastic while he's
dressed like Marlon Brando who we learn
before they share a birthday you know
they you know he shares a birthday with
Marlon Brando and he's dressed like how
he would look in the wild one but he's
talking like Vito cordial Corleone
another Brando character and the
Godfather we learn Wally has been on the
road and then he returned to pay his
respects because he learned that his own
Godfather sheriff Harry Truman was ill
he also wanted to let his parents know
they could redo his room to make a study
for themselves as mentioned this scene
is odd but fantastic and I'm not really
sure but this could also be hinting at
something else I mean it could just be
pure comedy but there there could be
something else going on here as well
after that we see Mike in the Red Room
and dougie coupe sitting in his bedroom
perplexed by these clothes that his wife
is laid out for him Mike is able to
communicate with him telling agent
Cooper he's been tricked he then shows
him the golden sphere or peril that we
saw come out of the real dougie Jones
whenever he was vaporized and then he
tells him something pretty important he
tells them that
one of them must die and he's obviously
referring to one of the Cooper's evil
coupe or the real aging tube who's now
druggie tube one of those two are going
to have to die they both can't exist in
the world at the same time we can't tell
us
Dougy coupe understands any of this but
we can see that he really needs to go to
the bathroom his wife comes in and he
sort of jumping up and down like a child
who needs to go to the bathroom and she
points him in the right direction and he
finally gets to go it's a pretty funny
scene and on the way out he catches
himself in the mirror and sort of stands
there and looks at himself after that
his wife gets some dress - the tie and
we meet sunny Jim for the first time -
dougie coupe seems to like right away
downstairs in the kitchen sonny jim
seems to be amused with dougie coupe but
at the same time he sort of helps him
sit down and eat some food so he's not
like a total little bastard or anything
but he at the same time this is all that
surprised that dougie coupe doesn't know
how to do these basic things then we get
one of the funniest seemed in an episode
that's full of them when Janie E gives
him his cup of coffee he seems to have
some memory of what it is but takes a
swig that he has to spit out which I
guess is because it's really hot or
whatever after that he says hi whenever
his wife yells at him which unless I'm
wrong it would be the first time he says
something that isn't exactly what
someone else like what he's just
repeating what someone else had just
said to him let's get a quick update in
South Dakota with the police
investigation there we find out the male
body in Ruth Davenport's rooms prints
came up but the identity was blocked by
the military Gordon Albert and Tammy
also arrived in South Dakota they
arrived at the prison after we learned
that Tammy gets carsick and we find out
the detectives are still analyzing the
poison he vomited up we assume that the
poison is related to his garment Basia
and we also learned that he had cocaine
a machine gun and a dog's leg in his
trunk dr. evil coupe who's in a separate
room and we noticed that he's changed as
well so the real coupe is
and in beloit almost and there's
definitely something up with evil coupe
- the way he talks is sort of like a
robot and it's just very unnatural
compared to what we saw in the earlier
scenes he tells Gordon that he's been
working with agent Philip Jeffries for
all these years undercover and says he
needs to be debriefed by Cole when the
three go outside Timmy points out all
the obvious problems with evil coupe and
what he said and asked about Geoffrey's
cold then scans her and says she's
wearing a wire what she points out he
instructed her to do and then he asked
her to wait in the restaurant so that
her him and Albert can talk one-on-one
after she leaves Cole turns up his
hearing aids all the way and they
discuss what they just witnessed it's
probably my favorite overall scene in
the return so far the look of it the
acting the sound and the whispering it
just had me on the edge of my seat and I
really felt connected to these
characters we also learned a few things
including me that they agree something
is definitely wrong and that Albert had
talked to and given information to
Jeffries years ago Albert tells Cole he
authorized Philip to give info to Cooper
who he said was in trouble he told him
who their man was in Columbia and a week
later that man was killed Gordon tells
Albert he doesn't like what they saw
with Cooper that it might have been the
accident but he didn't think so
and he says he doesn't think coop
greeted him properly he then says he
hates to admit it but he doesn't
understand the situation at all when he
asked Alberta P understands Albert just
answers blue rose and Cole says it
doesn't get any bluer Gordon then says
he wants one certain person to look at
coop and Albert agrees yes if he knows
where she is and Albert responds he
knows where she drinks at that point the
episode basically ends with the normal
ending which is the cutscene to the
Roadhouse with music all right if you're
a skipper and you skip the recap welcome
to the video so a lot happened in this
and you know I said in my three my SEPA
sewed
three recap that it was my least
favorite episode but I didn't really
think about it as these being two parts
that went together like part one and two
did in that way it's still you know I
still think the opening scene there was
a little bit too long but I do like how
these two episodes flow together so this
one was obviously a lot more
entertaining and you know there's
there's merits to both but I guess the
big mystery is right there at the very
end you know who is Gordon talking about
whenever he says he wants to see one
certain person and have them look at
Cooper who's you know before they make
any decisions now the first name that
comes to mind for me when I really think
about this is Diane obviously Cooper was
keeping those tapes talking to Diane all
the time she would be more familiar with
him than just about anybody else what
Albert meant by where she drinks I don't
know and I mean of course this could be
anyone but that's just who comes up to
me so let me know in the comments who
you guys think it might be I don't think
that the road house scene has anything
to do with that like I don't think
that's an indication that that's where
she drinks but I could also be wrong
there I mean it cuts to the Roadhouse
each time no matter what so I just don't
think that's a clue in and of itself the
Wally Brando stuff was hilarious uh just
acted great it was bizarre there is a
theory going around that maybe you know
because of that photo that we see - that
may be Wally actually died when he was
young and this isn't this is just a
replacement that's trying to get Lucy
who's acting crazy - you know kind of
move forward in her life but there's
really no other supporting evidence for
that it's just something to think about
like I said the Lucy stuff is weird but
you know I just thought I don't really
know what's going on with it it just
seems like all of her scenes are odd and
that she really shouldn't be so quirky
at this point able coop uh do you guys
have any theories as to why he's so much
different when they see him in the thing
I mean obviously he lost some gumbo
Rosia whenever he was almost stuck back
into the other side but do you think
that's what's causing that or
you think it's the fact that the real
coups back out in the world again and
somehow they're both kind of affected by
the other one I mean I think what's
really exciting here is that Mike gave
us that thing that we knew was coming
which is that the two Cooper's are going
to have to battle it out but if we look
at them right now neither one of them is
100% so I don't know how that's going to
play out but either way Dougie Cooper
you know the real agent coop who
everyone thinks is dougie is slowly but
surely getting a little bit more adept
and it seems like at least for the
moment doesn't pose an immediate threat
to him since he's locked up now he is
locked up in the same jail I think as
Ray I don't know that's been confirmed
but state prison South Dakota
he may be there to try to get that
information off of Ray although it
doesn't see I mean he you know it
doesn't seem like he planned to wreck
the car but who knows about that you
know either way he ends up there he
should be able to get his information
one way or the other
Gordon said he didn't think he grieved
him correctly he kind of caught that he
was really really after coop doesn't say
really really and then coop kind of says
everything twice after that which raised
red flags for Gordon like I said that
was by far my favorite scene I think I
mean with him talking now but I don't
know why it just was a really good and
well put together scene and I really
enjoyed that I don't know if it's
nostalgia or whatever but I really
thought that was cool and Tammy's
turning out to be a pretty good
character she's a little bit on the
outside still but obviously loved seen
Denise Bryson it's interesting and funny
to see her evolution of the character um
the company did a good job there I mean
she just is a day I mean she's different
but the same you know and still not sure
what's going on with dougie you know the
original dougie Jones bill Shekar seem
to know seem to know where he lived
doesn't mean much I did make a hole dug
evideo I think you should check that out
and listen to some of the questions I
have about that and leave some comments
because I'm going to be doing a part two
of that later this week
another thing that pops up here from
Bobby was that info about major Briggs
now I know a lot of people are thinking
that maybe the body in the bed myself I
thought about that myself that that body
might have been made
Briggs body was Ruth Davenport's head
what do you guys think about this idea
that he died at listening post alpha and
a fire 25 years ago I mean the
implication is obviously that evil coupe
was involved since he had talked to him
so does that mean that he actually
killed him like he set the fire or he
set the fire as a decoy as you know he
may be abducted major breaks or
something like that so let me know what
you guys think about that so far so good
as far as I'm concerned everything seems
to be going well the story is developing
we're getting more pieces to the puzzle
and I'm still 100% digging twin peak
season for you to return to this point
so let me know what you guys think
please subscribe to my channel and leave
a comment with any questions or anything
else that you're thinking about
I've been putting out a ton of Twin
Peaks videos so make sure you check
those out and I've got a couple lined up
this week so check back soon